foreign
welcome to Stanford I'm so excited to be
here I spent the last day watching all
of these view from the top
well great you're ready
so you have a lot of fans here at the
GSB in fact at our annual GSB show that
we had this past Friday there were so
many of my classmates wearing Rent the
Runway that we decided to have an
impromptu fashion show so let me show
you the video
because
[Applause]
[Music]
girls as players too
ladies get money all around the world
cause girls there's players too
just one thing
I think as evidenced by this video
to all the men in the room you are never
going to meet a crop of women ever again
in your life who are as awesome
beautiful smart ambitious as the women
who are sitting here
it up
if that's your preference if you you
know are into women
spend more of your time thinking about
dating when you're at school as one of
the key elements of success of Business
School
that's a great piece of advice I feel
like you can get an interview here
I'm so excited to talk about the
innovative business that you built but
let's rewind and start at the beginning
of your story you grew up in New
Rochelle New York as one of four
siblings tell me a bit about your
upbringing and how it shaped you
yeah so I grew up in a very close knit
super loving family which I'm very
fortunate for
I have a sister who is ex who's autistic
and she's severely she's severely
disabled so she is now 38 she can't live
independently she it's very hard to
understand her and it's been a 24 7 job
for my family and my parents to care for
her and it's been both you know a job in
terms of the heart and the actual labor
that it takes but it's also a
financially kind of
crippling situation to have someone in
your life that you love that you are
effectively supporting for their entire
lives and I really feel in many ways
that
my family
Dynamic and the team Dynamic that I saw
when I was a little kid actually
has made my life really about building
teams
so I very early kind of recognized that
number one
there's a lot to do when you have
someone in your family who has a severe
disability severe disability and your
parents are humans and they're going to
get tired and there were often times
that other siblings had to just step up
and lead and act like the mom or the dad
would have acted that we had to actually
be flexible in like what is our role in
the family and the second thing that I
recognized is when I was growing up in
the 80s if you had someone in your
family that was disabled most families
would try to hide that person away and a
lot of people were being
institutionalized or at the at the worst
and at the best people were embarrassed
and they wouldn't bring that family
member to a restaurant with them or to a
vacation with them and my parents had
this point of view that like
we love Sherry
yes she does crazy things but like it's
better to laugh than to cry and like
she's going to come everywhere with us
we're going to go to fancy hotels we're
going to go to nice restaurants we're
going to live our life and like who
cares what anyone thinks about us
and you know that mentality of just like
really turning things that could provoke
anxiety into like well that was a crazy
night like that's a crazy story that was
fun like as opposed to thinking about
the negative with it and also just
having this point of view of like we are
going to appreciate and enjoy who we are
in our life and so I think that when I
really was reflecting back that family
Dynamic really gave me the confidence to
think about like building you know teams
that I love being around lots of people
also the environment was so
one way to describe my house growing up
as energetic but in other ways it's just
total chaos all the time like four kids
an autistic sibling who's kind of the
equivalent of 15 kids like my parents
have an almost open door policy on their
life so they're always friends and
family kind of streaming out of the
house I actually love that environment
like recognizing about myself like
that's what brings me the greatest joy
it's be constantly surrounded by other
people that I love and I wanted to
almost create that environment for
myself not only in my job but create
that environment in my social life
create that environment in my community
that almost like Peak happiness for me
is being surrounded by a community and I
think that that recognition is what's
really driven my career
it also sounds like your upbringing made
you quite an empathetic leader as well
so you leave New York and you graduate
from Harvard as an undergrad and You
Begin your career at Starwood Hotels
where you soon find yourself as a 22
year old influencing hundreds of people
in the organization how did this come
about and what were some of your biggest
Lessons Learned
so I graduated college right after
September 11th and the travel industry
was in shambles because people were
scared to travel and I actually thought
that it would be pretty interesting to
go work for a travel company at the time
because I thought that they're going to
have to innovate or they're going to die
and so it might be an interesting
environment to be entrepreneurial
and I got there and the company was run
by an entrepreneurial founder and about
a year into working there I kind of
recognized that people were getting
married later people had different
values and as a result like Leisure
Travel had fundamentally changed and one
of the aspects that I thought could be
an opportunity was
couples who now wanted to potentially
register for their honeymoon and have
their friends and family kind of gift
them room nights or scuba diving or
massages instead of buying them pots and
pans because if you're getting married
when you're 30 years old you probably
have a frying pan already
and I went to the president of Starwood
at the time and at the time I think
Starwood had a few hundred thousand
people that worked there so like
creating a meeting with the president
it's like a 22 year old was kind of
crazy but I thought you know maybe he'll
give me 10 minutes of his time and I
pitched him on this idea of starting the
first honeymoon registry in the world
and kind of an Associated wedding
business around it that could kind of
capture a Leisure customer and create
loyalty with that Leisure customer and
he listened to me and you know he was
positive and then after the meeting my
boss I went downstairs and my boss was
like how did it go and I was like it was
awesome he said go do it he was like
and I just started to work on it I
basically like took this guys he didn't
quite say yes but he also didn't say no
so I took that as like yeah he really
likes this idea like he wants me to
pursue it so I started actually building
out this wedding business within
Starwood and again I was 22 no one
reported to me and I had to influence
hundreds of people around the world
in different divisions to help me build
a new website to help me build a new
piece of technology to help me build a
new reservation system like to tell me
take totally different photographs of
all of the hotels that emphasize the
pool and the Leisure assets as opposed
to like the the conference rooms and you
know you realized at that time that I
realized that you know I was doing
something that was
entrepreneurial right I was starting
something I had to inspire all of these
people who Jen's honeymoon business was
certainly not in their okrs but I had to
have them want to spend their time on
building this for me and so the first
aspect of this was like be likable
like no one is going to do anything for
you if you're not likable and number two
is like Inspire them with what we're
trying to create and what is the vision
of this and what is this new customer
experience and how is the world changing
and why does this relevant and kind of
getting people excited about it and that
was what was really amazing about this
experience I spent the next kind of
three years building this it became a 50
million dollar a year profit center for
the company it was recognized on Oprah
as one of her innovative ideas of the
year and it was just an exercise for me
and like you don't need to have
authority to actually be a leader
you can lead via influence you probably
see that in your own sections here at
school that there are people that kind
of influence the climate of and the
culture of that environment like that
kind of leadership like influential
leadership especially when it's positive
influential leadership is the most
powerful thing you can do because within
any company
like in most cases you're not going to
have full Authority
you're going to have authority over some
portion of the organization but what you
really need in order to kind of build
something and get an idea from idea to
actually execution is you need influence
and so that's what I really picked up
there
you learn to influence people as a 22
year old and I also love that story
because it highlights that you've always
had your pulse on predicting societal
shifts and Trends whether that be the
experienced economy or the sharing
economy and in 2008 you go back to
Harvard for business school and that's
when your idea for a closet in the cloud
was born
this idea was also revolutionary at the
time just to give a bit of context the
first iPhone had only been invented a
year prior and it would be years before
the likes of sharing economy companies
like Airbnb and Uber took off
Jen how did you come up with such an
Innovative idea I think that all great
ideas come out of
sometimes personal experiences which is
what this did this the first Inception
of the idea was
you know my sister I was home for
Thanksgiving break in New York City my
sister had just bought a really
expensive dress at a department store
called Bergdorf it put her into credit
card debt I'm her older sister I'm
staring at a closet that's filled with
designer dresses and I'm like Becky
return the effing dress like
wear something you already have and she
said I can't my closet's dead to me I've
been photographed the photos are up on
Facebook I need to wear something new
and
that was really a light bulb that number
one what she cared about was the
experience of walking into the room and
feeling awesome she didn't actually care
about this physical asset of the dress
and number two she thought this closet
that was probably her biggest investment
at that time was all dead
and I started thinking about like the
closet actually is dead it's this thing
that's a Historical Museum of who you
were in the past
and the idea was what if the closet were
alive and it could actually change with
you as your life changed and your size
changed and your mood changed and you
had the freedom
to actually Express Yourself based on
how you felt today and who you wanted to
be today and that was really the idea
for the closet in the cloud and this
idea of having access to whatever you
wanted to wear without having to own it
but then I started to think about okay
well
this is could be a good idea could not
does this already exist because often
even disruptive ideas like they already
exist it's just takes a change of how
you're thinking about you know the
situation to understand does this exist
and I started thinking about like you
know does this idea of renting clothes
or not having clothes forever does it
exist and I resolved not only does it
exist but this is like 85 percent of how
we already shop it's called Fast fashion
whenever you walk into a store and buy
something knowing
that you're going to wear it once twice
three times and then push it to the back
of your closet you're renting it
we've actually all over the last 40
years kind of grown up on this idea that
it's okay to buy things that you're not
going to use forever and you end up just
discarding them at some point or you
know pushing them storing them at some
point that is a very New Concept like no
matter where you are from around the
world think about your own parents and
how insane it would have been regardless
of their economic class to have
purchased 85 percent of the Wardrobe
that they have knowing that that stuff
was actually going to disintegrate after
they put it in a washing machine two or
three times which is what happens when
you buy things at Chien or Zara or h m
and so I thought we're already primed to
rent clothes and now all I have to do is
come up with a more Tech forward
personalized easier more luxurious way
to do it at the same price point as fast
fashion but give access to the real
thing so that was also what gave me
confidence that like the market already
exists and we could just create a better
kind of solution for how people are
already accessing variety in their
wardrobe you have this Innovative idea
and you've mentioned that there are a
lot of steps that you have to tackle in
order to actually get it off the ground
and one of the biggest questions you
have is how to get designer brands on
board
I'm curious what steps you took in those
early days to convince Brands especially
given you had no previous background
working in the fashion industry
so I had this idea on a Saturday night I
got back to uh campus on Monday I had
lunch with my friend and I always was
sharing kind of my hairbrained ideas
with her she listened to this one and
she was like that sounds like fun who do
you think we should ask whether this is
a good idea and I said you know I think
that we should ask Don Von Furstenberg
and my co my co-founder was like do you
know Diane von fursterberg who was like
no obviously I don't but like we could
probably figure out how to get in touch
with her and that afternoon we wrote an
email to a million different iterations
of dvf at dvf.com
and we figured one of those email
addresses would work and someone in her
office wrote back like I'll see you
tomorrow at 5 pm and so at Tuesday I had
the idea Saturday night Tuesday at 5 PM
I was with dvf introducing myself as the
co-founder of Rent the Runway and I was
kind of pitching her on this new idea
where we would you know get her
inventory current season rent it out to
customers and what did she think about
it and she
hated this idea
hated the idea
she thought that she's like why would I
ever do this like you're going to
cannibalize my entire business
who would ever run when they who would
ever buy when they could rent and as
opposed to what most people do in that
situation which is someone who's very
powerful and very cool and very famous
telling you like your idea sucks and
like why are you even here
most people would kind of be stopped in
their tracks like I was like okay let me
figure out all the reasons why she hates
this idea
and then I can use that to actually
modify the idea and change the business
I mean the business was three days old
so it wasn't really a business but like
I learned from her that her number one
Challenge and it was the challenge of
all designers was customer acquisition
that because of fast faction fashion
younger women and men were not trying
designer brands in the same way they
were before couple that with the fact
that younger people were not entering
physical retail stores in the same way
they were before so it was harder for
her and paid marketing costs were
extremely high so it was really hard for
her to acquire new customers and so by
the end of what became she won't attend
the meeting after five minutes we ended
up spending an hour and a half with her
in her office at the end of this hour
and a half
she was like laying down on a couch
eating grapes tossling her hair I was
like is this a date or is this I don't
know what was happening but it was
amazing and
I also learned that if I could create a
business that
helped her reach and develop brand
Affinity with the next generation of
consumers like that we might have
something that she would wanna
partner with us on and that's kind of
what she said she said you know come
back to me and I will meet with you
again and talk about that now also in
that meeting I asked her hey could you
introduce me to a few of your friends
and I'd love to meet with them and talk
about this idea because every meeting
has to get you to like three other
meetings and so never leave a meeting
with someone without asking them for
that introduction now those other
meetings led us to other people in the
fashion industry industry some of which
were designers some of which were
publicists like but people that actually
could give us real feedback on this idea
and people that could see that like we
were interested in listening it was
helping to build trust in an industry
where we had no experience where you go
in and you actually allow someone else
to give you feedback like how does that
work
what ends up happening in a situation
where I sit with you and I ask you
questions and I ask you for your advice
you end up walking out of that
conversation feeling awesome you end up
liking me in that conversation like
whenever you make someone else into the
expert like that builds a relationship
right away and we needed desperately at
the beginning of the business to build
trust so that anyone would actually
trust us to like take their currencies
and inventory and not cannibalize their
business so that was just a really
incredible experience dvf continues to
be an amazing friend of uh mine and of
the business today a huge supporter is
someone who like while the initial
reaction was like
this is not gonna work like she was
actually one of the first Brands who
signed on and you know has just been
incredible along the way that's a pretty
amazing lesson on the power of listening
and its ability to transform someone who
wants feed you as a competitor into what
sounds like a powerful teammate today
now that you have brands on board how
did you go about transforming consumer
business well getting brands on board
took years let me be clear like we
launched this company with like 20
brands most of those Brands were on the
verge of bankruptcy and that's the only
reason why they wanted to meet with me
why they wanted to work with us because
we wrote them a check with our VC
dollars
um and then it took me years to amass
the you know close to a thousand brands
that we work with today now over this
kind of period of time I have a hundred
percent retention of those brand
relationships so even though it might
have taken me eight years in some cases
or ten years in some cases to sign on a
brand once they start working with me
they see the value that we're bringing
to them as a partner and that's really
really important and that creates
positive word of mouth like positive net
promoter score in your brand value
proposition in addition to net promoter
score and your consumer value profit but
I think that like
if you're an entrepreneur if you're an
entrepreneur effectively you are a
salesperson
that's your number one skill that you
need to have and
when I was going to certain brands you
know they would be way harsher than what
dvf said you know they're the head of
one of the biggest luxury brands in the
world in the U.S told me hell will burn
over before I work with Rent the Runway
he said this to me he was sitting closer
than you are to me he was like screaming
his face was red and my reaction was
like thank you so much for the feedback
I'll come in I'll come back in three
months and like update you on our
progress
and by the way he's one of our biggest
Partners today and he forgot that this
happened
like if you ask him about this story he
was like he thinks I'm making it up I'm
like no there were eight other people in
the room like you actually said this
another head of another luxury band
threw his cell phone at me like he was
so angry with me that he threw his phone
at me like he's like we're never gonna
do this I mean so you have to just
almost like also Delight in like the
craziness of the experience that like
most people are not going to love your
idea initially and like sometimes like
they're not loving your idea for the
right reasons you can use what they
object to as ways that you can actually
innovate and modify don't use their
negative reaction as saying well they're
wrong
like had we not listened to dvf and
actually modified what the value
proposition was going to be for Brands
like we never would have brought gotten
the business off the ground
did your pitch to Brands and all the
lessons learned through that inform how
you decided to pitch to customers and
convince them to join the platform
um no I don't think that the brand value
proposition in our business like was
really related to the consumer value
proposition I think that we have always
been focused on trying to create a you
know incredible experience that women
would feel comfortable sharing with
their friends or anyone who complimented
them on their outfit they would say oh
thanks I'm I've rented the runway as
opposed to saying oh
yeah thanks I'm wearing Tory Burch or
thank you I'm wearing Philip limb like
imagine how impossible and expensive it
would have been for me had someone only
said I'm wearing Tory Burch or I'm
wearing Philip Lynn so I needed someone
to be so enabored with the experience
having felt so great by this kind of
Cinderella moment that Rent the Runway
was offering them that they wanted to
share the experience and to this day 80
of our customers come to us via Word of
Mouth our business is one that has never
really had to rely on paid marketing and
my belief set is that the only way that
you can grow a business over time is by
improving the value that you deliver to
the customer quarter over quarter like
the customer has to feel that the
experience is getting better and better
and that you were investing in her
in those early days too I can imagine
that some customers were maybe hesitant
to rent clothes that others had worn
before so how did you go about
transforming consumer Behavior to enable
customers to not only accept but desire
wearing clothes that others had worn
yeah so in 2008 like
and 2009 when we launched it was
actually considered absolutely
disgusting to wear clothes that other
people had worn before and so it was
really only kind of a first adopter sort
of community that would even give us a
chance and the fact that we had really
aspirational brands that people couldn't
otherwise afford was something that like
even if they thought it was a little
disgusting they're like but I'm getting
this two thousand dollar dress for like
a hundred dollar rental like I'll give
it a try and so part of what enabled us
to kind of
uh get consumers on board was one
remember the initial idea was for this
closet in the cloud and having a
wardrobe that was on rotation and I
recognized early on that that idea was
too big for where we were
in 2008-2009 that if I pitch this idea
of like renting clothes 100 days of the
year which is kind of how the consumer
uses the product today like people would
think that that was insane and the
business would have failed so we started
with the consumer value proposition that
was really easy for people to get their
arms around which is rent address
for a special event you know that you're
going to be asked to be a bridesmaid or
to go to a black tie party or to go to a
wedding and you're going to buy
something that you're only going to wear
once or twice so it doesn't make sense
for you to buy that dress so every woman
understood that
about the value proposition and
therefore we were able to kind of get
her on Board second was make it a luxury
experience so every aspect of the
experience felt luxury the from the
photography to the way that the site
looked to the packaging to the customer
service experience because the trick of
the what created so much brand love is
like you were getting a luxury
experience you were getting thousands of
dollars in value but you were getting it
at a fast fashion price point so that
was really the magic of the experience
so invest in every aspect of the
end-to-end experience and make it feel
luxurious
and the third aspect was kind of hustle
and utilize our own story as Founders
kind of put ourselves
front and center to try to get as much
earned media as humanly possible around
this concept to get people on board and
one of the craziest things that we did
that really exemplifies Rent the Runway
culture is we were like
we need to be in the New York Times
because
they have a lot of traffic and if people
read the New York Times then they'll
find out about Rent the Runway and we
literally had not launched the business
and I thought about okay how do we get
into the New York Times and I thought
okay well we're two women
and we're kind of starting a tech
company so they don't there's really at
the time there were no women starting
tech companies like let's try to find a
technology reporter because we're going
to be you know interesting to them
we then scoured like this whole list of
email addresses that we had kind of
created over the summer trolling through
people's alumni databases and we saw
that there was someone who was like a 22
year old Tech reporter at the New York
Times she had it at New York Times email
address and I was like let's get a
meeting with her let's like invite her
to this office for coffee and so we
invited her we kind of shared this whole
vision of what we were doing we were
going to revolutionize the fashion
industry et cetera she needed a story
because she was 22 she wanted to write
her own piece we needed her
and she's like okay I'm gonna write an
article
and then the second challenge was okay
well I didn't want it to be buried in
the technology section because then no
one was going to read it so I was like
can you come take photos of our
warehouse
and do you want to take photos of us and
she was like uh we'll take photos of
your warehouse but like no you don't
need to be in the picture I was like oh
well when's the photographer going to
show up and she told me when the
photographer was going to show up and I
told my co-founder I was like let's put
on our sexiest dresses right now let's
go to the warehouse let's run there
let's stand on ladders let's be in front
of the warehouse and we did it and we
posed in these ridiculous dresses in
this ridiculous fashion in front of
like a row of dresses and that photo
ended up on the front page of the New
York Times A1 section on
newyorktimes.com we had a hundred
thousand people sign up day one of Rent
the Runway and we met our first year
sales Productions in the first three
weeks and so like press baguette's press
number one but number two is like create
your own luck like this woman was
effectively like no way you're not going
to be in the photo like and who knows if
they're even gonna use the photo I'm
like I'm gonna create the story and so
that sort of like
creating the story and hustling for it
is first of all what makes
entrepreneurship fun but second like
something that I hope is still embedded
in our culture you know 15 years later
that's amazing I'm definitely hearing a
theme in all of your experiences of you
being Scrappy and being the ultimate
Hustler which I think is a good lesson
for all the aspiring entrepreneurs out
there
I want to Pivot now and talk a bit a bit
about your experience raising money so
you're obviously operating a very
inventory heavy business which requires
a lot of capital
can you talk a bit about your journey
raising money from a predominantly male
VC industry convincing them to invest in
a business catering exclusively to women
um raising money
something that I found to be very fun
because I love painting the picture of
what we were doing how we were going to
disrupt the industry what the trends
were that were kind of leading to this
point where Rent the Runway could be a
viable business and it didn't dawn on me
until like many years into the business
how
Bleak it was for female entrepreneurs to
be able to raise money so a lot of the
early experiences that we had where
people were kind of rejecting us I just
thought like they were rejecting us
because you know the idea wasn't right
for them or you know they just didn't
like the idea I didn't actually think
that it had anything to do with gender
now if you look at the data like there's
a lot that has to do with gender in that
the metrics around dollars going to
women have been around two percent for
the past 25 years and they've only
gotten worse and those metrics are even
worse as it relates to people of color
women of color you know anyone who comes
from a different background
so
I think that we had some interesting
experiences
at the beginning where I remember an
early kind of seed Round Pitch we did
where we were pitching to two partners
of a very kind of prestigious VC firm
and I know that I'm a great
salesperson pitcher I had gotten great
feedback on this pitch from others and
at the end of the presentation like he
took my hand in his one of the partners
and he was like
you're going to have such a fun closet
of dresses to to dress up with this is
going to be so fun for you and like kind
of
treating me in this way of
that he thought that this was just like
some cute girl and some cute idea and I
think that that really has like driven
me
to want to just prove people like that
wrong
and that the only recipe is just
continuing to move forward like there's
going to be people like that there's
nothing that I can do to change that guy
all I can do is like go pitch more raise
more money build my business try to make
that business successful and just
continue to like put one foot in front
of the other so I think we have I think
that there aren't that many solutions to
this problem except
ensure that
my business can be as successful as
possible so that when other women are
trying to raise money that they have the
pattern recognition of like well there
are these other women who have been able
to do it
well you did impressively raise over 400
million dollars in VC funding and with
that Capital you're able to grow the
business and in growing the business you
had the best months in Rent the Runway
history in January and February of 2020
up until that point
and then obviously covet hits and women
are no longer leaving the house
how did Rent the Runway change as a
result of kovid and how do you now think
about navigating turbulent times
so I had been building run the runway
for 13 years when covet hit and first of
all Rent the Runway is my first child
like the love of my life I build this
company because I actually do want to
change the way that people feel about
themselves every day I love my team and
there have been thousands of people over
time that have been contributing to this
big vision and this big idea that we
have and have put in their Blood Sweat
and Tears into taking this from like
what was a very crazy disruptive idea
into really pioneering a category
so we had had this incredible
few months
um prior to the pandemic or you know
many years prior to the pandemic we had
launched a subscription to Fashion which
was growing like crazy so your vision of
the closet in the cloud was actually
coming to fruition people were using
this to get dressed 80 to 100 days of
the year they were renting the runway
for their everyday life and then on
March 12th
2020 we lost like 80 percent of our
Revenue overnight
and
we clearly like there's really not a use
case for variety in your wardrobe which
is what Rent the Runway is about
if you are on your couch
like there's really nothing that you can
do to kind of drum up demand
and initially
I didn't want to accept that
and I spent the first
few weeks
um
trying to like drum up marketing ideas
with my team of like how are we going to
bring customers back what are we going
to do and there was a moment where like
I was on zoom and my husband kind of
came into the room after I'd like signed
off a zoom call and he's been like and
he was like Jen
you run this company and you've been in
the same pajamas for the last two months
no one is going to rent clothes right
now like
stop thinking about this and save the
company and I think that
the first lesson is like when you're in
any crisis you have to ground yourself
in reality
and grounding yourself in reality is
often a very difficult and harsh thing
to do and it's especially a harsh thing
to do when you're leading a team of
thousands of people
and at the same time that I was trying
to ground the team in the reality that
like this is going to be really bad for
us for a long period of time I had to
inspire the team with hope
that there was a reason to still believe
there was a reason to still believe in
our vision that our vision actually was
going to serve the post-covet world even
more even better and that we can use
this period of time when essentially our
Revenue had kind of moved away to
transform and innovate the business in
ways that we may not have been able to
when there were all of these orders kind
of
coming through the site all of these
orders coming through the Warehouse
Etc so it was a absolutely
horrific period of time on one hand
because I felt like
the huge amount of emotional stress that
I needed to save the company not just
for myself I needed to save the company
for the thousands of people who had
believed in me who had dedicated their
time over many years in helping to
create this company and it deserved to
exist
and so we had to
I I had to basically become
the most decisive version of myself
and every single day I would
make dozens if not hundreds of decisions
it's very clarifying to be in that
situation in some senses because you
realize like what is your core business
what do you think it's going to be when
you come out of covid and like
what what do you what can you need to
slice away a lot of the business right
now we need to let go of hundreds of
people which was incredibly difficult we
needed to let go of lots of different
work streams and divisions of the
company we had to simplify the business
and those times of crisis in a sense
there was like deep clarity
around
what is the simplest version of what
this product needs to be and how do we
actually
get really laser focused on here's the
three things that we're going to do over
this period of time that are going to
help the business transform so that when
we emerge from covid we can emerge as a
fundamentally different and stronger
business than we were before
that's amazing that you were able to
keep the business afloat during that
time and you impressively go public in
2021 fast forward to today nearly 15
years after your founding after you've
pioneered a new way to shop the market
is now not only full of other clothing
rental platforms but also resale players
how do you think about differentiation
given the market
so first of all I'm really proud that
there is a circular fashion market right
now that we were a part of pioneering in
that circular fashion Market is global
and it's enormous and it's growing
and I see that
the
the market no one consumer is going to
just have one modality for how they
think about clothing how they think
about their wardrobes
if you think about most Industries on
Earth you're offered a choice as a
consumer for how you want to consume in
that industry based on what your need or
your use case is so in the world of
Transportation you can own a car at the
same time if you're going from point A
to point B you could decide you want to
take an Uber if you are going on a 7 or
14 day business trip you can rent a car
for that period of time you can there's
different options for you to get from
point A to point B
in fashion before Rent the Runway you
had one option which was buy something
and own it forever
and so what I see red the runway is
doing is we're really owning kind of
that last Mile in the same way that Uber
is helping you get from point A to point
B anything that you want to kind of
utilize in your wardrobe for like three
months or less you should have it as
part of your subscription like
this dress I might want to wear it a few
times and then I'll send it back I'll
get something new that should be part of
your rental rotation
what is resale
resale is a leasing model
okay like resell is if you want a new
bag
every year
you want to keep that bag for a year and
then flip it out like that makes sense
to utilize resale because it's a
long-term leasing model
and then ownership should be something
where you invest and you have those
things forever they should be very high
utility items that you get a lot of use
case on so you should own an amazing
black blazer you should own amazing
cashmere sweaters like the closet should
exist with all of these options and the
consumer when given a choice I think now
can like rethink how she spends her
money and actually have the freedom to
think about those items that like you
know with rental as an option you have
the freedom to express yourself in a way
that like you didn't really have before
and you can kind of wear something
that's a new color or a new trend and
have fun with it without having that
burden of knowing you have to own it
forever so I see resale as being
incredibly complementary to what we do
I see the fact that there are other now
real competitors that we have in the
rental space in the subscription space
as being amazing
it is unbelievably difficult to create
an industry explain how this whole thing
works get you to use it as a consumer
improve continuous Mark you know
continuously Market this new industry
like if there are competitors who are
also marketing this idea of subscribe to
Fashion all we have to be is the best
all we have to do is own who our Market
is and own who our consumer is and
because I think that this is such an
enormous Market fashion is a 300 billion
dollar market just in the U.S it's a two
and a half trillion dollar market
globally and I personally think that
because 80 percent of the closet is worn
three times or less that there is a huge
amount of the closet in the future that
can actually move to this idea of a
closet in the cloud
it also seems to me like in this crowded
Market one of your main differentiators
too is your Reliance on data I think
many people may view Rent the Runway as
solely a fashion company but in reality
you are a massive Tech and Logistics
operation that has figured out how to
expertly use data to understand consumer
Behavior can you give us just a few
examples of how you use data
yeah but you kind of skipped over like a
really crazy part of the story which is
like the business died right like we had
no revenue and
we were then innovating and I had to
raise like vulture Capital to keep the
business alive which was an insane
experience
um and then a year and a half later we
ipo'd the business and
it was
the most incredible experience that I
have ever had in my life
to
IPO something and see thousands of
alumni around the runway and employees
have Rent the Runway come back to New
York during covid to
celebrate this and the number of people
who were able at that point you know
when you're kind of a boss or you're a
leader like someone works for you and
you know when they leave Rent the Runway
like you don't really know or you don't
really hear like what impact Rent the
Runway has had or not had on their life
and the IPO was this unbelievable
experience where like
I heard from
thousands of employees that like this
experience working around the runway had
transformed who they were and
transformed their life and had made them
dream bigger for their own lives and
they had now become their own
entrepreneurs or they had met their own
co-founders or they'd taken big jobs
somewhere else and you know I think that
like there are those moments in a
business career that are harrowing like
managing through crisis and managing
through
um a pandemic and then there are these
moments that are so incredibly special
where you realize that you know you're
making even a a small impact on how
people feel about themselves and on
their lives and you kind of have to
treasure those incredible moments of
Celebration as the fuel to kind of keep
you going and enable you to kind of
keep on putting one foot in front of the
other so I just wanted to go back to
that IPO because it was like
unbelievable that we were able to do
that
and thank God we ipoed when we did
because a week later the market crashed
and we never would have been able to go
public and the business would have gone
bankrupt at that point because we needed
that Capital that we raised in the IPO
to bring the business to profitability
and so
there was just a really miraculous
period of time that I'm extremely
grateful for and the team that kind of
stayed
so committed to this Vision it is the
most special thing in life to not only
have your own passion and your own
vision and conviction for something but
when you see that other people take that
on as their own and when other people
act like real Founders in your business
and in your idea and that we've done
this together like that is the most
special experience of my life that it
wasn't about me taking the company
public everyone who was there felt like
they took the company public that they
built the company and like that's what I
kind of wish for you all of you in the
room that like you are able to build
something and have a career where you
feel like you've done something
with a group
where like you're part of a community
that's changed you know the world in
some way because that feeling of doing
something together is like
the most incredible feeling in the world
that's amazing and thank you so much for
digging in deeper there but we can go
back to data if we want we can talk
about that but in the interest of time I
want to open it up to audience q a there
are so many other parts of your story
that are interesting and wait no I want
to talk about one other thing first okay
you can also do that too okay I want to
talk about
this concept of view from the top
and how challenged I was
to kind of think about
myself even giving this conversation
today
because by no means do I think that I'm
at the top
and I don't even use that as a parameter
for how I want to think about my life
like what is being at the top mean
like
I have achieved incredible Career
Success but I still think I'm at the
very beginning of what I want to build
and innovate and create for Rent the
Runway I want this business to be really
sustainable I view that so much of my
life and what is going to make me happy
and what does make me happy has nothing
to do with a successful career it has to
do with the fact that I have a wonderful
marriage and I have kids who I love and
I have incredible friendships and I
invest in those friendships and
sometimes I you know now that I've
watched like 12 of these talks over the
past two days
I've seen that there are a lot of like
you know luminary people and they come
here and they talk about like their
Career Success and like give this notion
that what we're trying to achieve is
being at the top but it's like if we all
think about our lives that way of trying
to get to some destination you're not
going to be happy like the life is about
the journey the thing that I'm proud of
about Rent the Runway is the everyday
moments over the past 15 years where
I've just had the time of my life like
who really cares like what does being at
the top mean does that mean an extra x
million dollars in the bank like what is
that really going to bring to me what so
I think that we should just all think
about like
the goal is the journey and enjoying it
the goal is like what is optimized
around making you happy and for some of
you that's going to be
very career related
but for many of you it might not be and
that is totally okay and part of what
you should be doing here is figuring out
like what fundamentally about you is
going to make you happy
like the realization for me going back
to my childhood is that it's community
that makes me happy and so like
entrepreneurship is just my way to like
pay people to be around me all day long
right like so I built my own community
and like that makes me really happy and
I've built other communities of my
family and friends Etc but like
I just don't think that many of the
people that I used to when I was in
business school and I looked up and I
said well they've created a
multi-billion dollar company they're
sitting here they're a billionaire
they're successful it's like
if you really talk to a lot of those
people like
that's not how they measure even
themselves
like there are so many aspects of
your life that are you can achieve all
of this Career Success and if you don't
have the other things in your life that
you really care about like it's really
not going to be that meaningful so we
have to focus on like the whole picture
I appreciate you saying that because
there's so many mba2s and audience
you're about to graduate so thank you
Jen thanks so much for being here and
sharing your story and I particularly
loved the elements of hustle that you
shared throughout your story
um a lot of the women in my life love
rent the wrong way that's awesome um I
was curious if Rent the Runway could
work for men and why or why not
I think that there's definitely more of
a market for men today than
when we founded the business men are
becoming more and more interested in
fashion
but I think that great businesses stay
focused
and we can do so much more for our
female customer that we have today we're
just scratching the surface on the
customer experience and I think that it
would actually be
detract an enormous amount from the
experience to start to focus on an
entirely different customer set right
now who has different needs who thinks
about the product in a completely
different way so even 15 years into the
business interestingly like I think that
we still have a massive massive
opportunity ahead of us and the goal is
like continue to stay focused on it it's
View From The Chop tradition for us to
end with a quick lightning round okay if
that sounds okay to you great okay great
dream job when you were a kid
um being a pop star
it's not too late for that oh I'm
working on it
advice you would tell your younger self
this is a
specific
um
real advice is
do not stress so much about getting
married you'll get married
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you'll find the love of your life like
it'll happen like don't let it paralyze
you
know that's great most fun piece of
clothing you've rented
I rent clothes about 350 days of the
year for the last 14 years so there is a
lot
um
well I'll just tell you one last weekend
I dressed up with my daughter as we were
both Harry Styles I wore a silver sequin
stripe jumpsuit that looks exactly like
Harry Styles she had her own matching
one and we sang with a band in front of
her birthday party so that was just
really fun about like using Rent the
Runway to you know do something crazy
and wear something that's certainly a
one-time thing it's amazing
and finally an atypical view from the
top lightning around question but is
there any discount you can give to your
GSB fans out there
I think we have something for all of you
guys thank you so much what is it well
hopefully a promo code oh it is yeah we
have a promo code we want everyone here
to have a subscription and we're giving
it to all the men too so give it to any
woman in your life that you want and
thank you guys so much for having me
here today thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you
foreign